you
of all the singers Sarah Vaughan is
every singers favorite singer or else
they just don't know and I was just so
happy to meet her and was the ultimate
compliment in the ultimate moment when
she invited me into her vocal booth and
closed the door behind her so I got to
hear Sarah sing a capella with her
headphones on and she made me bully
obeys and requested me to do her album
cover in those days there were no stylus
or makeup artist for jazz artists it was
kind of not fair there were budgets for
rock and roll but not for jazz back in
that day and Sarah had you know she was
a big woman she she wasn't petite and it
was easy to take an unflattering picture
of her let's put it that way so I
thought about what I wanted to do and I
wanted to do homage if you will to the
black gamma campaign that Peter Rogers
had done the brilliant Peter Rogers what
becomes a legend most and all of these
women legends would have their four
coats and be hugging themselves in the
fur coat so I had that story in my mind
to do that and the day came and it was
the most exciting day and I asked but
she bring her coat and her gowns and
everything and she apparently was
terrified of having her picture taken
maybe because she had so many bad
pictures taken and I went downstairs and
she got it at the limousine shaking her
head no I don't feel well I'm really
sick let me go home and she hadn't even
come into the building so I said just
come upstairs for a minute she came in
the door and really like a scared cat
sit bring me a chair because she didn't
want to go further then right inside the
door so she SAT there and she peeked
around and saw the lights and got even
more scared and she said oh please
please I'll come back tomorrow come back
tomorrow and
her managers on the phone saying is she
there don't let her leave she'll never
come back and then out of nowhere she
said do you like chili and I said chili
is in Chile and she said yeah she said
she had sara had a great like a little
girls speaking voice you know she said
oh I'll come back and chili for you
tomorrow let's make a shopping list so
my said assistant you know chopped meat
onions whatever it was that that was on
the list and she and I thought oh she's
tricking herself into coming back to
cook for me whatever so I said okay
under one condition you have to leave
your main code here and she said no
problem no problem so I took the coat I
put it in the back walked her downstairs
and her driver who was her driver back
then was equivalent to people's kind of
advanced people in bodyguards now you
know she knew how to protect herself and
he said where's the coat and I said the
coats staying here and he didn't like
that and I said the coats staying here
and then the manager called me about 10
minutes later and he said listen if you
want to leave the house tonight you just
call me and I'll send a couple my
nephews over to watch the house so
everybody was worried about the coat and
she did come back right on time singing
singing making her chili in my kitchen
saying are you stirring that Jilly while
she's having her makeup put on and it's
a picture i'm really proud of